this video is brought to you by manscape
comm we are huge fans of manscape they
are the only men's brand that's
dedicated to grooming and hygiene and
they got a new product now the weed
whacker and it's a ear and nose hair
trimmer so as you get older somehow your
nose hairs start creeping past the
border right here and before you know it
it looks like you just got all these
weeds growing out of your nose and
here's the thing guys you don't want
your beard to start from your nose it
doesn't work that way you know
especially if your Asian is just the
Asian man syndrome and it starts coming
out so for me I get like these long
hairs that come out and what sucks is I
also have allergies so sometimes I'll be
sneezing and I take like 3-4 allergy
pills
and I'm like why the hell am I still
sneezing and I looked in the mirror and
I see one of those long hairs I'm like
oh I should have pulled it out if I had
one these guys could have clip it but
when you pull it out with tweezers it
actually hurts a lot cuz it's the really
thick one that's been growing and keeps
curling inside so I'm glad that manscape
sent me this guy so man escapes
revolutionising the nose hair trimmer
they spent years just redesigning with
new materials making this stuff so
freaking cool and it's all made for
performance and comfort and yes
it's comfortable oh there's yeah it
works great with this shape you could
probably even use it inside of your but
if you go ahead and they're true and
they're skin safe technology prevents
Nicks snags and tugs which are very
important because it could be painful
see Jose has no pain right now feels
good actually I can hear it cutting all
the hair it's working it has a powerful
9,000 rpm mortar with a 360 rotary blade
system to whack all the weeds everywhere
it uses an intelligently contour design
which is about a 23 degree Anglin which
matches the natural organ Onyx of your
nose you know it curves like this or
even if you put in here and curves like
this it is a fact when they pulled 79%
of
partners that long nose hairs is a
turn-off that's a lot of people that
says Oh baby I don't like that so
something upgrade your manscape routine
with the new weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer if you use are called JK
news you could get a 20% discount and
clear your nose that's a good deal of
hair and we'll have the link in the
description so go down there and click
it and clean your nose hairs coach Jake
a news 20% off the baby thank you to
manscape for keeping our nose trims and
our pubes free of weave I could breathe
better have you guys heard about John
Krasinski's show I love him I haven't
seen him but I heard he's gonna report
the good news he did a prom well people
are mad at him oh oh yes good finally
maybe it was bound to half this wait
just wait till she resists [ __ ] can you
read this is just me just me wait just
hold on just wait because he punched a
puppy because okay so some good news
he started this during the whole
quarantine stuff yeah he was barred
everyone was at home and everyone's like
oh my god like you know this world like
we don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
oh my god oh yeah oh my god only bad
news is happening in the media like
people are dying left to write this
crazy
so John Krasinski decided to create this
youtube series out of his office in his
home called some good news so he was
just like you know what we need some
good news in this world dope he did an 8
part series and to the point where I was
like filled with celebrities he even
like got people married over zoom in you
and they did the whole like beyond song
yeah no funny if they're getting mad at
him because he's not reporting actual
like bad news cuz they're like you have
a platform you should be spraying real
news that's happens everybody right it's
not even that deep no exactly okay so
all right the whole like the whole
premise of it is like I'm starting this
because we need to spread some good and
it's like it's so genuine and like
authentic right I feel like a lot of
people are like this is tight but then
it gets reported that he sold this show
to Viacom yes a horrible news I'm
actually in a massive bidding war among
other networks and stuff to the point
where they sold it they didn't say they
didn't specify how much but it's like
rich like they're saying using the word
rich big bags so their colors they're
saying you sold out yes yeah that's the
worst one really but I loved them
actually I think they're great I work
with anybody I love you well what did
they what did they want TLC they own
everything
no they're mad then you [ __ ] even
sold it exactly so everyone's calling
him a sellout they're like what the [ __ ]
dude like you made this [ __ ] out of like
it seemed like the kindness of your
heart why would you make money out of it
he's like go [ __ ] yourself I [ __ ]
made this show yeah well the thing is
too is because like a lot of it was like
YouTube monetization is horrible it's
horrifying yeah it's a fan submitted
things and like so he would have like
these fans and these celebrities that
would join then join him in this show so
a lot of people were like you just used
yeah do you think it was maybe because
he started during a pandemic so he kind
of used when people were at their lowest
I'm assuming here when people are at
their lowest now he comes in with this
authentic like hey I'm just here to
spread good vibes love trying to connect
people and then later we find out that
he kind of kept my kids drew the side
and then his kids like yo God you give
us [ __ ] $175,000 or [ __ ] you we own
the side he's a
I mean a hundred percent that's how
people are mad yeah they feel like he
did it out of the goodness of his heart
what you do and and what you did maybe
they maybe didn't but it's also his job
yeah but now that like shows I know but
you can't see it like that cuz like you
have a different perspective because
you're in the industry secret Jim I love
you but let this product reflect that he
sold out we don't even know what the
show where I'm like it's like you don't
even know cuz I'm thinking if he's still
running it if it still him now with the
budget he could make it better let me
clear that out for you he will not be
hosting it anymore it's sold out it's
over we're good you're right so he has
defended like selling it right so he
said that he had always had in his mind
that he was only gonna be doing eight
parts of it no second you should have
told us because he said he said that
there's no way it's sustainable like he
has other projects other things that you
think Jack Ryan's month and YouTube
doesn't pay well Jack ridings fun to
watch on Amazon yeah and like all these
things that he has on his plate where he
was like this was not sustainable for me
to continue it so I'm so happy that you
know it can live on it doesn't
necessarily have to have my face on it
but I will be behind the scenes he said
um we have a lot of really fun stuff
planned and I can't wait to dig and I'm
going to be a part of it whenever I can
and I'm going to host a couple episodes
and bring on a different community of
people I received the most amazingly
kind notes about how much the show meant
to everyone but the truth is it meant no
more to anyone than me that's probably
the most emotionally fulfilled I've ever
felt in my entire life so I sold it to
find I know kick it worst of that basil
there he's like that's why I sold it to
Comcast I love that Comcast yeah but he
was insisting I am so passionate this is
the most rewarding thing but I gotta get
off my plate cuz I got these other
projects I need to deal with who I sold
it to Big Oil
there's good people at Big Oil you know
so how did this happen like did it did
okay so the show started
then it got sold and then people found
out or did he like give a disclaimer
like hey guys just want to fill you in
it's gonna be sold no it was either like
sold and then I don't know yeah I think
that's a little bit probably doesn't
know how to YouTube right you know
because we always keep people in the
loop transparent as long as you keep you
transparent then people are like okay
that's cool
like guys they get it already done in
eight episodes but now all these studios
they want to buy the show and he's like
I think I'm gonna sell ya because I know
how much this means to you and I don't
want to stop this is obviously not
sustainable to me because I have Jack
Ryan I have these projects but I want to
keep this going
yeah well it's not happen not to get too
mired to into inside baseball do it I do
remember if you remember I do when
YouTube started to give grants to too
big people got to build the verticals
right so they're building out a bunch of
vertical to give Sarah Silverman a
company called Jash basically like if
when they give you money to build out a
whole little separator like everything
where you can create more content came
out of that right I love those sounds
and Mickey yep Mickey Meyer a great guy
Sarah Silverman joined it Michael Cera a
bunch of people joined that but it
wasn't [ __ ] real money to them it was
real money to tubers like it was
millions of dollars but most of it went
to a traditional media correct yeah all
of it went to traditional media but then
the problem with Hania traditional media
is that those cats are like well cool
I'll do eight episodes and then like all
take a break for [ __ ] twelve months
and everyone's like [ __ ] you that's not
how YouTube works and they didn't know
that and so exactly it's the same [ __ ]
it's the same [ __ ] the only vertical
that was successful and that was vice
and Yahya meth actually Phil did yeah he
did he did SourceFed on them and it
worked out really well you know the
thing about it is like people are so
entitled right nowadays the viewers they
expect all the give me give me give me
give me right and it's like out of like
yeah like a stop out of like again you
know and especially for a dude like Jim
from the office yes who he comes from
Jim
traditional media yeah close up on that
that's what she said where it's like
this is in all media and he's like I'm
gonna try and do something for fun and
he even warned people I'm only gonna do
a little bit and he's like of course as
soon as you do something successful the
big company is gonna want to hop on it
sure and what's what's what's silly from
the people is that like the big company
is taking over it doesn't mean that it's
gonna change well the quality of it a
lot of people were thinking like so
they're like this is one tweet for
example remember when he created this
feel free feel good YouTube show to make
people feel good and now he is selling
for money
they're really cool 100% honorable yeah
for sure but like a lot of people are
speculating like wait is it gonna go
behind a paywall now like this was
supposed to be something that oh my god
they're gonna have to pay for it right
yeah like we don't know that for sure
and and then another thing too is like
you know we joined because we like you
John you know that is people be good
yeah yeah me oh gee we should we should
have Steve on yeah they're saying that
the host will need good news Peter deep
Steve goodness very good yeah to me I'm
like this is his show he could do
another [ __ ] he wants with that yeah pay
while sometimes whatever business you
start off snot sustainable and now you
figured out a way to make sustainable
yeah if you got log in to your Comcast
account to access the show even better
they didn't even watch what was his
movie quiet quite place yeah they
probably didn't even watch I feel like
it's the same kind of group that's like
a part of like you know like super
underground scene or whatever like when
people have something that's special to
them yeah they feel like they actually
own it and then they don't want it to
change
and in characters and actors and things
like that like when fandom gets a hold
of it they take it personal yeah and it
becomes a [ __ ] weird man but I do get
the whole like I thought you were just
doing this as a passion thing and oh man
I kind of feel like you're just greedy
but if you pay if you were really paying
it
[ __ ] wish I was he [ __ ] had the [ __ ]
promoted by Viacom before he sold the
Viacom if you look so yeah NBC ABC every
[ __ ] buddy was promoting the show
oh is it cool John Krasinski's doing
this show and I'm not kidding it was on
every pre-sold probably basically was
and so then it's not a big [ __ ] shock
that all these cats jumped on board
because they only do that when something
becomes mainstream I see yeah it was a
game bro it's always a game bro it's
always a game exactly right now is a
game that was a game if you know what
the game was though then you know what
the game is but you don't know the game
how much is vikon paying us talk about
it
nothing hello that's it we're doing this
in a storage container bro that's true
we're just giving them free promotions
whenever kids comment on my [ __ ] and
they're like bro you sold out I'm like I
[ __ ] wish I saw down but they don't
want to give us anything to sell out
whether like bro you sold I'm like dog I
had the opportunity to sell out oh my
god dude who wouldn't want to sell out a
show they don't even know cuz YouTube
conversations like yo man we're your
brand deals right now all that so sick
I'll suck your [ __ ] dick if you tell
me if you give me a contact they have no
idea yeah and it's so funny like some
people really believe that if you have a
brand your sponsorship your all of a
sudden now just sold out and it's like
how the [ __ ] do you think we survived
yeah I know
I remember when I first started putting
ads on my on like my channel at all
just like ad rolls regular ads people
like bro I can't believe you [ __ ] out
so we have ads now yeah wow you put ads
and you knocked em stay [ __ ] poor I
want you to struggle not even be able to
pay your [ __ ] bills right B me too so
I can watch a free entertainment yeah
you really offended and entitled to the
fact that like wait you know you can't
shove anything in front of my face well
you know what's cool though every time I
do read in the comm is like more people
are understanding of the business side
of entertain that's
now to say [ __ ] there's so many people a
tree on like you first came out it took
years yeah
how many times did we all see that
happen and I used to criticize patreon
even sometimes like cuz it was kind of
silly back in the day because some of
the pitches were nuts but but they all
have fan bases it's fine
but then I'm like man when you watch the
Super Bowl and everyone's like this is
your brother so I love how that you've
relied watched for the commercials then
you realize how Santa Claus our world
really is I don't see anyone getting
pissed with the 100 million dollar Joe
Rogan deal let's modify no everyone's
happy that's money right there like oh
because like we're oh geez in this
YouTube [ __ ] right but like over the
years people kind of understand how this
[ __ ] works now so like now as opposed to
back in the day where I would put ads on
my vlogs or whatever people true bro you
[ __ ] slow it out now when you go to
YouTube
when you get a brand deal Instagram
brand or whatever everyone's like oh get
that bad get that money yeah I watched
the whole ad just for you guys don't man
think yes you like a commie like sellout
and then you see ten other comments
underneath like are you [ __ ] dumb are
you a kid you're [ __ ] talking a simp
and iPads are the [ __ ] and then the Cubs
are like somebody have a ball game about
well no that's not what I like like
years - yeah like I'm with you guys like
I'm so happy that by now everyone's like
cool we're all on the same page but it
literally took like five years it's
crazy yeah I don't know I mean good for
John but I guess backlash oh come on
they're just haters bro but I want to
hit on until I'll hit on - dude I hate
on him because he's married to Emily
Blunt she's my favorite person I like
John Doe I love John well you only love
John cuz you loved Jim mmm no you need
to watch Emily Blunt in interviews you
will [ __ ] fall in love with her they
all love her so much I refuse
she's funny as hell
[Music]
[Music]